I know what you're thinking Michael I
love you thank you very much I love you
back you're very lovely believe it or
not though there are some people who
don't love me there are some people who
don't even like me you're a monster and
they've made mean tick tocks to express
their contempt for yours truly
this video is brought to you by Birch
gold more from Birch gold in just a
moment first though let's get to the
mean tick tocks Michael why don't you
know how to operate a washing machine
and why are you proud
saying like
have to have I have to have my wife walk
me through it are you that dumb
are you that stupid it's
self-explanatory I'll teach you so you
put the laundry in okay hold on put a
pause right there first of all the
washing machine that I got when I bought
my house was the previous owner's got it
is some weird Scandinavian spaceship
thing that only has one button and 300
settings this is too much this is
nothing yes the machine that she's using
there looks relatively I still probably
couldn't do it but it looks relatively
easier to use but the one that I'm using
you need an advanced degree which is why
I have to turn to my PhD wife you can
choose what kind of wash you want you
can literally pick normal almost every
time it will wash your
and then you hit the start put a mouth
on this girl by the way you can say that
it just doesn't come naturally to you
and that's why you can't figure out how
to work a washing machine but that is
not it you're just lazy this is pretty
you're just treating your wife like your
mom
and that sucks for her
you like that she in your
World in your religion your reality you
like that your wife has to do all that
because you just can't be bothered
with it you don't know how to do your
own laundry and you look like you're
pushing 40. look like I'm pushing 40.
hold on do do the cigars and the coffee
and the whiskey and the general lack of
water does that really age me so much I
guess it does she makes an interesting
point here where she says Michael you
treat your wife like your mother I guess
in some ways I do and that when I was a
little kid growing up my mother would
cook my dinner and now I'm an adult and
my wife cooks my dinner but I don't
treat my wife like my mother I treat my
wife like my wife that's a crazy idea
when she says you treat your wife like
your mother you crazy awful terrible
conservatives she's admitting that there
is such a thing as normal gender roles
oh I gotcha she wants to deny the gender
roles for the wife but she's
acknowledging the natural gender roles
of the mother she's referring to the
type of the mother but the wife is just
a mother to somebody else overall though
there was a funny that was a funny bit I
I got a kick out of her even as she
criticized me next one I'm kind of
familiar with this argument that like
Hunter you've never actually talked to
any of the smart conservatives can you
give me an example of a smart
conservative Michael Knowles Matt Walsh
was wheeler so Michael Knowles says both
the libs and conservatives taking
freedom of speech to an absurd extreme
invoking it to justify all manner of
historically unprotected speech such as
a blasphemy Etc blasphemy I'm pretty
sure the Constitution directly talks
about how the state should not demean or
uplift certain religions
the Constitution very much doesn't talk
about that yeah yeah tell
what is he talking about is he is he
referring to the First Amendment which
says that at the federal level there
won't be an established church that's
true that doesn't mean that the
government can't demean or uplift
certain religious views the reason that
the First Amendment prohibited the
establishment of a church at the federal
level is because there were already
established churches at the state levels
at the state level the churches did
uplift one religion and shut out other
sorts of religious views but but even
beyond that the state for virtually all
of American History has had blasphemy
laws such a profanity The Summer's still
on the books they just aren't really put
into practice but no we've outlawed
blasphemy for much of American History
this by the way from the smart
conservative you referenced because
Michael Knowles is smart enough to
realize that that the founding fathers
wrote the Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution knowing those
freedoms weren't weren't established by
some random government Authority they
were born with those rights they were
granted by a Creator and that you cannot
speak out against that Creator no this
is directly in contrary to let the
founding fathers believed in how America
was formed so America began literally
because they didn't like the fact that
there was an enforced religion over in
England where they all had to attend the
English church they didn't like that so
they set up America so that you could
practice your own religions
he's going all the way back so not just
to 1776 but to 1620 when some of my
ancestors came over very religiously
zealous people on the Mayflower and he's
right that they came over because they
did not like the Church of England but
they did not come over because they
believed that you had a right to your
religious views and in fact when those
Puritans in Plymouth and Massachusetts
Rhode Island when they established their
colonies and people dissented from the
established religious views there they
would banish them get out of here and so
that goes back to 1620 then you come up
through 1776 and the founding fathers
after the American Revolution and what
did they say did they say we have rights
because we say so and you can think of
everyone no they said our creator endows
us with certain unalienable rights and
then furthermore John Adams says the
spirit of America the the moral order
that will order America will be the
Christian moral order
what this guy hunter I think he said his
name was what he says is that's what are
you talking about that's crazy doesn't
the Constitution and then he just rants
about something that he wishes were in
the Constitution but he's just pulling
that out of thin air notice he's not
citing the Constitution he's not citing
the early Americans he's not citing
American law obviously he can't because
all of that backs up what I have to say
and so what he is doing is what the
liberals so often do which is they will
merely State their own views and their
own preferences for how America would be
governed and then they will say and
that's what America's always been about
from the beginning but they never quote
anybody and they never cite any sources
and they never cite American history and
how the country's actually developed in
practice because they know that it
contradicts the fantasies that they want
America to be you know when when we want
to tether our society to reality one
great way to do that would be to have
real money and when you want real
tangible assets you gotta check out
Birch gold the FED has a tendency to
print money during times of economic
distress like they did during the
covid-19 pandemic this has resulted in
the loss of value of a dollar and an
increase in the value of precious metals
like gold gold will always have inherent
value because it's a tangible and finite
resource uncontrolled by any single
government or financial institution as
the value of our dollar declines it
becomes increasingly important to hedge
against inflation by diversifying at
least some of your assets into precious
metals the only company I trust to help
you diversify into precious metals is
Birch gold Birch gold makes it easy to
convert your IRA or 401K into a tax
sheltered Ira backed by physical gold
and silver with an A plus rating with a
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company that I
trust to protect my future so should you
right now text Knowles Canada w l e s to
98 98 98 to claim your free info kit on
gold and talk to a precious metals
expert you get that info by texting
nulls kwlas to 98 98 98 hi guys okay I'm
not doing too good right now but I would
really appreciate it if you take the
time to watch this whole video please
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the whole
Preposterous ideology at every level
okay so that happened just a few days
ago but let me read you a quote that's a
bit older it is recommended that the
phenomena of transvestism is
exterminated from public life did you
guess where that's from the quote I just
read was said in 1930 by The Institute
of forensic medicine in Nazi Germany
exact same thing is being said today by
conservatives they do not want us alive
repeating itself history is repeating
itself everything that I don't like is
Hitler goodness gracious me in that
speech that she quoted the exact quote I
said was for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
a transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life
entirely the whole Preposterous ideology
at every level I've now memorized it
because it's come up so much I don't
think she needs to look to 1930s Germany
to try to infer and Intuit what I meant
I said it pretty clearly I said for the
good of the people especially who've
Fallen prey to this confusion so
presumably I wouldn't want to murder
them I use the term eradicated which is
to pull out from the root so you're
correcting the premises of this ideology
these people seem very upset and they
seem very unhappy and they seem like
they've got a tenuous grasp on reality
and it would probably be good to help
them to become more grounded in reality
rather than to fly off the handle and
cry because I made a perfectly fine
speech look at little Goblin Jr I'm
gonna cry I do not know how to operate
the laundry machine in my home I don't
know how to do it
on maybe a couple of occasions when my
wife said oh could you go put the
laundry in I have done it I have had to
ask her to guide me every step of the
way that is not something naturally
yeah 10 year olds know how to do laundry
like if you don't have the mental
capacity of a 10 year old and you can't
accomplish tasks that a literal child
could accomplish your opinion shouldn't
matter about anything
does it bother you to use inclusive
language it's just interesting I prefer
to use precise language I'm sorry you
can't press start on a machine you can't
read the the label it's labeled for you
literally okay one more time again I
have a very fancy laundry machine okay
I didn't ask for it I didn't buy it
it just came with my house and I don't
speak Norwegian or whatever I have to
speak to get this thing to work and it's
I I'm not def I'm I couldn't probably do
it even on a regular laundry machine or
I wouldn't take the time to at least but
please I want everyone to understand I
have a very very fancy washing machine
Mr fancy pants for anyone who's unaware
of the terminology this is called
weaponized incompetence it's also called
manipulative oh that is so interesting a
person uses this to avoid having to do
an action again in the future it also
puts the responsibility of the test
complete
she's not wrong
[Applause]
you know I mean I'm happy to call that
Bronte when she gets things wrong she
often does pregnant person it's true I
don't I don't want to do the laundry and
so I I don't make any effort to get good
at the laundry so whenever someone does
this it means that they don't care about
their partner they have little value for
their partner because they don't care
that it's going to take their partner
extra time energy and effort to
compensate for their pretending
competence that's really it says a lot
about you as a person she she gets a lot
of things wrong and one of the things
she gets wrong is feminism
feminism insists that men and women are
exactly the same we all we need to split
the house chores 50 50 and you I watched
11 dishes tonight so you better wash
eleven two or else it's not totally
that's not how it works that's not how
it works because men and women are
different we have different strengths
and we have different desires we have
different Natures measures of Happiness
over the last 50 years since the Advent
of feminism show that men and women have
become less happy and women have become
less happy even less happy relative to
men why is that because of the great
wonders of feminism Yes actually
feminism didn't deliver it's okay it's
okay for the wife to do the laundry it's
okay for the man to bring home the bacon
probably you're going to be happier that
way what's my favorite one you know the
answer it was the first one it was the
washing machine gal she's an articulate
gal she's pretty funny nice young
attractive lady she can do better quit
spending your time criticizing a lovely
fellow such as myself focus on reality
find that to be a little more edifying
perhaps you've been sanctifying see you
next time
[Music]